RET RECORDINLEGE PLANNINFOROATHS
VIOLENCEN .
E ERARE BEING CHCONSPIRACY IN WH
CARRIEA MU OF
20RS BEHIND BARS.
SARA SIDNER, AND FORMEFBI
SPECIAL AGENMIKE DRUMMOND.
YOU ON.
H, I WANT TO GET TO YOU
BECAUSE THE SECRET THAT WAS
COURT TODAY, WHANED TO
LOOK THOT OF
SOMEONE WHO WAS ON THE CALL.
IT WR PLANNING
CALL ACCORDINGTHI AGEN
TAN STAND TO
VERIFY THE VOIS WORDS
WERE COMING OUT OF THE
H OF SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF
THOATH KEEPERS.
INCLUDSTEWART RHODES, THE
LEADER ANDOATH
TLY RECORDED IF 2020.
THIS WAS OBVIOUSLNGBEFORE JANU.
SOHIG WITH HIS OKEEPER
P.
WHAT HE SAYS.
A NOT GETTITHIS
WIFIE IS GOING T A FIGHT.
T T'T SMART.
D LEE PRESIDENT
D SORT OF TALKINF FINDING IN TE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD LOST
TION AND THAT JOE BIDEN
WATKINS, WHO POS SAYSSIC
YSINAS A
ANSGENDER PERSON THAT SHE WAS
YIINTO THIS GROUP.
ANKELLY MAGSBOTH OF OM
ARE SEN F THE CAPITOL,
OADS, WHO ONLY SEEN
OUTSIDE THE CAPITA
WEAPORECORD
OTWEONTO BRING INTO THDISTRICT O
ABOUBRFIS PAICS LLGSAB.
PEPPERAY,INAUDIBLE]
PIPE WITE ITSN HUR
E,-
I HAD MY HELMET IN MY AT WAS --
]
THE FACE.
A NOVEMBER 14TH BIG MAGALYIN THO
NUIT'S HADN'T BEEN PLANNEDERE
LKING T
NEVER MENTNEARY SIX IN
PLAYED TO THE JURY.A LO WHAT YOD
THER GOES TOHEAT THESECUTORS WER
TT IINHEOF STAGES,F THISLAN, T F
POWER GONE?
DEFENDANTSKECNN AFTER
CO WHAT ARE THEYG?
>> WE HEARD FROM THOMACAWEND YOU
WHS.
HE IS A NAVY BETTER D,
AN ACTUAL  OF THE SEOF THIGOHEEL
ATE
CALLIN ASSOCIATE OF THE
OATH KEEPERS ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNMENT, THE ER OF ICK REACTS
LOT ABOUT BRINGING
VNIA, T
IA, ATEL,
IN ORD TO BRING THEM OVER --
WH TMETH
E
UNQUOTE, NEEDED  TSCENARIO OY S.
BUT HERE IS WHAT HE SAYS.
IT WENT
WAS A LONG WAY TO
NGO ,
THE TRUTH IS GOING T!
ALL FAITH IN MY LORD
ANOR JESUSHR I
E FINE.
IMF
COURT TODAY.
S IN QUITE WATCHING THEPRDI ANDH
ING TO PROSETORSSTHAT HE AND THT
NSFER OF POW
WHY THEY AREA
SEOU, CONSPIRACY.THE
THEYTTORNE
BASICALLY SAY LOOK, ID A
TALKING, A T
BOMBASTIC THINGS.
IT'S ILLEGALY AREG ABTHATY T REE
HOW THIS ALL
BUT THA OL
EVIDENCE, DON.
FEDERAL PROSECU, THE OEPERIN DM
EVIDENCE -- ARGUMENTH EXY.IT'S
PROVE  THAT
ANLY IS AGREEMENTS IN
REALTIME.
S HAPPENING.
SO IT'S REALLYEVIDENCE.
ANK  AC
THE PROSECUTORS TO PUT THIS
RIH ,
T T THE RET LASTED
ROUGH JANUARY SIX.
CLEAR THE SICK RNG AS THECRIME.O
MONTH.EMBER OFWAS GIVEN TO THE T
21 THE TIP, TO THE F,
COULD VIOLPREVENTED ON THEI
HAD IP SOONER?
IS JUST ONE
INFORMN AVAILABLE.
ANW
T  WERE
THAT THEATRIANISMS
WARNING --
E
ENCE THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY
E T E HEARNTY SIX E KOUT FOR
C AY WAS
COAN 2021.
ING THAT THE
E DOMESTICREAT TO OUTHAT'SEACOU.
TETHEY WOULD HAVBEEN AHEADT KIAS
ON T RADAR.
E BOTHERING ME DURING THAT PERID
LOT OF THE VIOLENCE THESE
ERE ENENG GHEYERID
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THEKEEPERS WE
WITH W
T BUEGON, --
MO REFUGE.
SO THIS IS RESISTAE TO
ENT -- CRIMINAL
PREDICATFOR THE FBI, TOSTIFY A .
WE OY ROUPS
TH WEREN'T THEREJANUARY
SIX.
SO DIDN'UNDENDALL
OF THESE GROUPS  THE SAMTIA
LEM.
BE HERE?G IN FEDERAL COURTWHEREA
PRODUCERS WHO E COURTROOM.
BUT JUST
TRANSPARYOU KNOW?
SAID AND QUITE AS INSENT BEINGC
IN SOME FOT S
SEEING IS BEINT?
SO IF THS PELETALKING, WHEN THED
REDIRE AATION --
Y HELPS PAINT A PICTURE
FOR THE PUBLIC.
BUT'-
CAD IN THE COURTS.
ANIN T, IT IS REALLY
HE JURHEARS WHEN
YOU ARTALKING ABOUT JUSTIC
IT'S ABO W H.EVIDENCE THE JURAN.
WEEKS,D I GOTTA TELLS
INURIS GOING
WITH THEIR VERDICT.THROUGH TO TC
THERE  A!
EVER SEEN OF
CE IN THIS CASE.
USE FIVE DEFNTANEATH
A LOT TO SEE HE